[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ihn allen einen schönen
guten Abend Katja du sortierst später
die wieder die sportlichen Neuigkeiten
sehr gern ja guten Abend dann blicken
wir jetzt auf die Themen an diesem
Dienstag dritte Insolvenz in wenigen
Jahren Galeria karstadtkaufhof ist
wieder pleite tausende Mitarbeiter um
ihren
Job vor dem Streik im Bahnverkehr ab 2
in der Nacht legt die
lockführergewerkschaft GDL wieder weite
Teile des Zugverkehrs
l Erinnerung an die Ikone des deutschen
Fußballs die Sportwelt trauert um Franz
Beckenbauer für Mitarbeiter von Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof kehrt eine Unsicherheit
wieder die sie nur allzu gut kennen
dürften Deutschlands letzter großer Kauf
hauskonzern hat wieder Insolvenz
angemeldet zum dritten Mal innerhalb von
4er Jahren wie schlecht es für die
Warenhauskette lief verdeutlicht diese
Entwicklung nach der Fusion von Galeria
Kaufhof V Karstadt 2020 gab es
deutschlandweit 175 Filialen viele
mussten seitdem schließen waren es
vergangenes Jahr noch
129 sind es heute nur noch 92 Filialen
jetzt also
Insolvenzverfahren Nummer 3 und das
bedeutet auch mehr als 15 000
Beschäftigte müssen wieder um ihre Jobs
fürchten mehr von Sven
rieen die Wintersonne scheint auf eine
der lukrativen Filialen des Unternehmens
des karstadthhaus in der Hamburger City
von 1000 Mitarbeitenden sind hier 250
geblieben die Umsätze Stimmen und doch
müssen auch die Kunden nun schon zum
dritten Mal ein insolvenzhaus betreten
und ich habe gerade vor einer Woche noch
eine Kundenkarte hier besorgt aber das
ich bin da sehr deprimiert eigentlich
ich will es nicht hoffen denn irgendwie
finde ich doch wä es doch schön wenn
hier in der Stadt doch noch wenigstens
karstadtkaufhof bleiben könnte seit
heute Vormittag heißt es nun
Insolvenzverfahren eingereicht am
Amtsgericht in Essen drei große Aufgaben
haben Insolvenzverwalter und
Geschäftsleitung für die Häuser müssen
die Mieten runter das Unternehmen
braucht dringend neues Geld also einen
Investor und es braucht neue Ideen für
neue Kunden das heißt allerdings nicht
dass alle Häuser erhalten bleiben stand
heute haben wir 92 Filialen die werden
wir stand heute weiterbetreiben aber wie
gesagt die vermietungsgespräche muss
noch laufen und dann muss wir die
Konsequenzen Zehen mit ren Benko kam
nicht der erhoffte Wandel sondern wurde
alles komplizierter so muss der
Insolvenzverwalter über Mietsenkungen
mit vielen verschiedenen Unterfirmen
verhandeln teilweise auch mit deren
Insolvenzverwaltern immerhin die Löhne
der Mitarbeiter sind erstmal gesichert
wir haben jetzt den
insolvenzgeldzeitraum bis Ende März die
Agentur hat hat ähm hat mitgeteilt dass
Insolvenzgeld äh auch in diesem
Verfahren gezahlt werden wird Hoffnung
und Wahrheit liegen zumindest in der
Hamburger City nur eine Straßenbreite
weit auseinander diese geschlossene
Filiale ist auch für die verbliebenen
Mitarbeiter gegenüber eine stäte Mahnung
wie es auch enden
kann trotz juristischer Unsicherheiten
hat der gdlstik wie geplant veror gut
einer Stunde begonnen zunächst im
Güterverkehr um 2 Uhr nachts soll dann
der Personenverkehr folgen das letzte
Wort hat aber das Landesarbeitsgericht
Hessen dort wird in diesen Minuten über
eine Klage der Deutschen Bahn
entschieden die den Streik noch
verhindern will unabhängig vom Ausgang
des Eilverfahrens gilt morgen ein
Notfahrplan der Deutschen Bahn mehr von
Isabelle de la
Vega die GDL will streiken für mehr Geld
vor allem aber eine kürzere Arbeitszeit
bei vollem Lohnausgleich für Millionen
Reisende gilt ein Notfahrplan
80% der Züge fallen aus jeder muss
umplanen weil alle betroffen sind gut
die die Leute die dann arbeiten gehen
können dann Homeoffice machen aber sonst
ja man ist ein bisschen hoffnungslos ne
ich wollte am Freitag
zurückfahren und werd dann
wahrscheinlich am Samst halt fahren ne
ich frage mich dann schon ob es nicht
auch ja andere Lösungen geben könnte die
dann nicht so sehr zu Lasten der
Kundinnen und Kunden der bahen gehen
würden die gab es offenbar nicht ein
neues Angebot der Bahn zu flexibleren
zeitmöglichkeiten schmetterte die GDL ab
das verbesserte Angebot ist ein
vergiftetes Angebot die
arbeitszeitabsenkung ist selbst zu
finanzieren das ist großer Schwachsinn
das hat mit der forderungslage nichts zu
tun die Bahn versucht bis zuletzt den
Streik per Gerichtsbeschluss zu
verhindern derzeit wird noch vor dem
hässischen Landesarbeitsgericht
verhandelt Bahnkunden sollten jetzt den
Notfahrplan checken und können falls ihr
Zug gestrichen wurde die Kosten
zurückbekommen alternativ kann das ti
auch nach dem Streik noch genutzt werden
und bei den aktuellen Streiks ist es so
dass die Bahn das Kulanzangebot gemacht
hat dass die Zugbindung wegfällt das
bedeutet ich kann meinem mit meinem
gebuchten Ticket auch auf andere
Verbindungen umsteigen z.B auch wenn ich
ein Nahverkehrsticket gebucht habe und
auf den Fernverkehr umsteigen möchte
mehr Infos über Umbuchungen Erstattungen
und die Gültigkeit von Tickets gibt es
auf der Seite der Deutschen
Bahn zu viel Bürokratie und keine
gerechte Bezahlung dagegen haben die
Hausärzte in Deutschland zuletzt immer
wieder protestiert darum heute ein
Krisentreffen mit dem
Gesundheitsminister ein Ergebnis das
Ende der Honorar Obergrenze bedeutet
Hausärzte sollen künftig keine festen
Budgets mehr zugeteilt bekommen die
waren ja problematisch weil das Geld
teilweise vor Quartalsende aufgebraucht
war und Ärzte dann quasi unbezahlt
weiter gearbeitet haben mehr von
heikeans ob Hausärzte oder Ärzte vielen
niedergelassenen Medizinern reicht es zu
viel Bürokratie zu wenig Zeit für
Patienten zu gering der Ertrag am Ende
des Monats auch deshalb haben tausende
Praxen zwischen den Jahren gestreigt
wenn eben eine gewisse Leistung nicht
vergütet wird dann wird sie eventuell
nicht mehr erbracht wenn ich Termine
deswegen nicht mehr zur Verfügung
stellen kann weil eben das Geld nicht da
ist dann fehlt halt auch an der
Versorgung überfüllte Praxen aufnahmest
man Orts Versorgungsengpässe deshalb
Krisengipfel beim
Bundesgesundheitsminister mit
Ärzteschaft und Krankenkassen Lauterbach
will nun den Hausärzten Entgegenkommen
verspricht ein neues Vergütungssystem
das den wirtschaftlichen Druck nehmen
soll das nicht im Vordergrund steht wie
oft muss ich den Patienten einbestellen
um das volle Honorar auslösen zu können
sondern die vorhaltepauschale und diese
ganzjahrespauschale die gibt es für die
Einschreibung und dann wird auf
medizinischer Ebene entschieden ob da
tatsächlich der Besuch in der Praxis
notwendig ist auch fachärzteevertreter
fordern die Aufhebung der gedeckelten
Honorare fanden aber beim Minister
vorerst kein Gehör wenn die facherz und
facharzte entbudgtiert würden würde es
wieder mehr Termine für die Patientinnen
und Patienten geben das heißt das lange
Suchen nach einem facharztermin könnte
dann wieder ein Ende haben das bedeutet
natürlich dass auch möglicherweise die
Beiträge zur gesetzlichen krankenvier
steigen müssen die Versorgung soll
besser werden umstritten allerdings zu
welchem
Preis 2024 wird ein Superwahljahr in
Deutschland viele Parteien nutzen darum
ihre traditionellen Klausuren zu Beginn
des Jahres um erste Themen zu setzen so
auch die Grünen sie forderten erneut
einen gesetzlichen Mindestlohn von 14 €
die letzte Anhebung sei größtenteils
durch die Inflation aufgefressen worden
sagte grünchefin lang außerdem will die
Partei eine schnelle Entscheidung über
Lieferungen von
taurusmschlugkörpern an die
Ukraine jetzt nach Frankreich zu einem
politischen Neustart der erst 34-Jährige
Gabriel Atal wird neuer Premierminister
des Landes und damit der jüngste
Regierungschef in ganz Europa Präsident
macron reagiert so auf schlechte
Umfragewerte vor der wichtigen
Europawahl und auf Querelen innerhalb
seiner Partei über die Erwartungen an
den politischen Shootingstar und macron
vertrauten berichtet Anna Warsberg aus
Paris
expremierministerin born übergibt
weniger als 24 Stunden nach ihrem
Rücktritt schon das Amt an ihn Gabriel
tall 34 Jahre alt bisher
Bildungsminister und jetzt jüngster
Premierminister den Frankreich je
hatte ich möchte den Franzosen sagen
dass sie immer auf mich zählen können
dass der Präsident und ich Ihnen jede
Stunde Minute und Sekunde widmen werden
er gilt als enger Vertrauter macrons
medienpräsent eloquent und er soll neuen
Aufschwung bringen laut Umfragen liegt
macrons Partei nämlich momentan hinter
Marine Le Pen rechtsextremer Partei
rassemblement national und das vor den
anstehenden Europawahlen
2024 das Jahr in dem auch die
Olympischen Spiele in Paris stattfinden
sollen ein Event an dem macron das Land
sicher als zumindest nach außen geeinigt
und handlungsfähig präsentieren will
2023 war das Jahr der unbequemen
Reformen erst die Rente dann das
umstrittene verschärfte
Zuwanderungsgesetz musste elisabeet born
ohne Mehrheit im Parlament durchboxen
Gabriel Tal schaute ihr da noch
zu Atal müssen wir jetzt erstmal
kennenlernen er hat bisher eine sehr
schnelle Karriere hingelegt deshalb kann
man seine Fähigkeiten den Staat zu
lenken noch nicht
beurteilen dai hängt es jetzt von den
Geschicken des neuen Premierministers ab
künftig Mehrheiten im Parlament zu
organisieren und damit steht und fällt
auch der Erfolg von macrons restlicher
Amtszeit kann der frühere US-Präsident
Trump strafrechtlich verfolgt werden
wegen Vorgängen in seiner Amtszeit darum
geht es heute vor einem
Bundesberufungsgericht in Washington DC
obwohl er selbst nicht zum Termin
geladen war nimmt er persönlich Teil die
Anhörung bezieht sich auf ein Verfahren
gegen Trump wegen versuchter
Manipulation nach der Wahl im November
2020 seine Anwälte argumentieren Trump
habe als Präsident absolute Immunität
genossen und könne nicht für Handlungen
von damals verfolgt
werden bundesaußenministerin bbock ist
weiter auf n ostreise heute hat sie die
Grenze zum Gazastreifen besucht im
ägyptischen rafach forderte sie einen
leichteren Zugang für humanitäre Hilfen
es könne nicht sein dass sich Trucks
tagelang stauen sagte bärbock zuvor
hatte sie sich mit dem ägyptischen
Amtskollegen getroffen und für eine
Feuerpause
geworben vergangene Woche in Portland
USA eine Boeing vom Typ 737 MAX musste
notlanden mit einem Loch in der
Außenwand kurz nach dem Start hatte sich
ein Teil vom Rumpf gelöst einige der 177
Passagiere an Bord erlitten leichte
Verletzung jetzt wird klar der Flieger
der Alaska Airlines ist kein Einzelfall
weitere Fluggesellschaften fanden an
ihren chinen gleichen Typs ebenfalls
lockere Schrauben Thomas
gon zwischen Zweigen ein Flugzeugteil in
einem Gärtchen in Portland eine Art Tür
sie zeugt von einer beinar Katastrophe
vor vier Tagen eine 737 MAX 9 wie diese
hebt ab 7 Minuten später das Teil ist
rausgerissen neben den Passagieren
schwarzer Himmel in 5000 m Höhe es gab
einen lauten Knall das war unglaublich
angsteinflö
dre Reihen vor dem Loch sitzt Kelly Bley
ein Passagier ist näher dran der soiss
sein Shirt vom Körper der
Sicherheitsgurt hat ih das Leben
gerettet die Landung dann sicher nun
laufen Untersuchungen Ermittler sagen es
löste sich eine Platte auf einem
möglichen Notausgang verschlossen weil
hier nicht
gebraucht alle Z Befestigungen haben
sich gelöst sass das Teil aus dem Rumpf
flog und die Ursache Kontrollen gebe es
regelmäßig Verschleiß Scheide wohl aus
so Experten das Flugzeug war ja relativ
neu das hatte überhaupt erst
230 240 Flüge hinter sich von daher muss
es sich um einen Herstellungsfehler
gehandelt haben möglich also dass Boeing
oder ein Zulieferer schlampte auch bei
weiteren typgleichen Maschinen dort
fanden sich nun lose Schrauben und Teile
betroffen Alaska Airlines United
Airlines immerhin für Flugreisen in
Europa besteht keine Gefahr die Zahl der
737 MAX in dieser Konfiguration die in
Europa fliegen ist sehr überschaubar ein
Dutzend seien es alle werden überprüft
jetzt schon gewiss die Zweifel an Boeing
werden nicht
kleiner südkorea will bald das
Schlachten von Hunden beenden das
Parlament hat ein entsprechendes Gesetz
auf den Weg gebracht demnach sollen das
Töten und die Zucht von Hunden sowie der
Verkauf ihres Fleisches zum Verzehr ab
2027 illegal sein verstöße werden dann
mit bis zu 3 Jahren Gefängnis bestraft
Hundefleisch zu essen hat eine lange
Tradition in Südkorea noch immer gibt es
etwa
Zuchtfarmen wer wissen will wie wir in
Zukunft leben der sollte nach Las Vegas
schauen dort auf der CES einer der
größten Technikmessen der Welt haben
viele der wichtigsten Aussteller nichts
weniger als den Beginn einer neuen era
ausgerufen die Zeit der künstlichen
Intelligenz und tatsächlich verblüffen
immer mehr Anwendungen auch im Bereich
Gesundheit Benjamin Daniel
berichtet künstliche Intelligenz das ist
gefühlt die Überschrift der diesjährigen
CES fast kein Produkt kommt mehr ohne
sie aus dieser Spiegel beispielsweise
trifft anhand eines gesichtscans
Aussagen über meinen
Gesundheitszustand Blutdruck
Cholesterinspiegel Herz Infarktrisiko
vieles mehr einige Werte hatte ich erst
vor kurzem beim Hausarzt checken lassen
und tatsächlich sie stimmen ziemlich
genau während des Scans werden
blutflussmuster unter ihrer Haut
analysiert so können Aussagen zu
Vitalzeichen oder Erkrankungsrisiken
getroffen werden das ist zwar keine
Diagnose aber ein präzises
Risikoprofil diese Drohne transportiert
Laborproben und Medikamente sie ist
schnell klimaschont und kann zum B und
Entladen an Fensterbänken andocken alles
voll automatisiert die KI hilft auch
wenn es Probleme am Himmel gibt wenn
Objekte auf einmal aufk
Fallschirmspringer ein Helikopter ein
Flugzeug paragleider irgendwas was leise
ist was vielleicht kein transponter dran
hat dann müssen wir das auch wieder mit
Hilfe von künstlicher Intelligenz
erkennen können bei all der Technologie
Euphorie geraten kritische Aspekte in
den Hintergrund dennoch setzen sich
Entwickler natürlich auch mit Fragen zum
Datenschutz oder Gefahren von KI
auseinander wer geht wie mit welchen
Daten um wer entwickelt Modelle was
machen diese Modelle das wissen wir eben
oft nicht deswegen muss man so ein
bisschen Skepsis davor haben Angst würde
ich sagen nicht weil wir habenich im
noch die Kontrolle über solche Systeme
es liegt also in unserer Hand und das
wird hoffentlich auch so
bleiben so jetzt zum Sport und Katja die
Fußballwelt trauert nach dem Tod von
Franz Beckenbauer weiterhin ja
vorgestern starb der fußballkaiser im
Alter von 78 Jahren und die Zahl derer
die ihre Trauer zum Ausdruck bringen die
steigt stündlich darunter sind auch
viele internationale Fußballgrößen und
in München wird ab morgen ein
Kondolenzbuch
ausliegen Abschied nehmen von einer
Fußballlegende Blumen an der Bayern
Geschäftsstelle seberner Straße und am
Geburtsort von Franz Beckenbauer in
München giiesing aber natürlich auch
weltweit die zahlreich Reaktionen zum
Tod des Kaisers ger liniker Beckenbauer
einer der größten des Fußballs der alles
gewonnen hat mit Eleganz und Scharm ruhe
in Frieden das wünscht auch Lionel Messi
und David Beckham würdigt ihn als wahren
Gentleman Sportart übergreifend der
große Respekt Dirk Nowitzki er hat die
letzten Jahrzehnte wie kein anderer
geprägt einfach einer der größten also
wenn man so eine
sportgröße wird ist dann muss man das ja
auch erstmal schaffen als Mensch so zu
bleiben wie der Franz das geschafft hat
Anerkennung für die Lichtgestalt des
deutschen Fußballs und auch wenn es
Schatten in dieser sonst so großartigen
Karriere gab eine mögliche Feier in der
Münchner Arena wäre ein würdiger
Abschluss für einen der ganz
Großen im Handball hofft nicht nur
Bundestrainer Alfred geslerson auf ein
Wintermärchen morgen beginnt für die
Deutschen in Düsseldorf dieem mit dem
Spiel gegen die Schweiz in der
Fußballarena von Düsseldorf heute das
Abschlusstraining morgen dann der
Weltrekord 53 000 noch nie haben so
viele Menschen live ein Handballspiel
gesehen Rückraumspieler Julian Köster
ist voller Vorfreude alle haben einfach
Bock auf dieses Heimturnier auf dieses
erste Spiel hier vor so einer
Rekordkulisse von daher ja beste
Bedingung es geht gegen die Schweiz 18
der letzten 20 Duelle hat die DHB
Auswahl gewonnen aber Vorsicht sieben
Schweizer spielen in der deutschen
Bundesliga darunter Torjäger Manuel
Zender der Druck morgen der der liegt
auf jeden Fall bei den Deutschen weil
sie gewinnen müssen hier im eigenen Land
aber auch wir haben uns hohe Ziele
gesetzt wir wir wollen die Deutschen
morgen schlagen und wollen auch eine
Runde weiterkommen für die deutschen Gil
verlieren verboten denn im
Turnierverlauf warten noch
nordmazedonien und Olympiasieger
frankreicherlich gegen die Schweiz keine
Niederlage erlauben dürfen weil dann
warten ja vermeintlich noch stärkere
Mannschaften von daher wissen wir dass
das erste Spiel ein Endspiel ist aber
darauf sind wir vorbereitet das Ziel ein
Wintermärchen wie 2016 da wurde
Deutschland zuletzt
Europameister und das spielbt dann
morgen wo zu sehen im ZF danke schön so
sie können sich warm anziehen weiterhin
wetterdetails gibt's gleich von Christa
Orben wir empfehlen Ihnen ab
21:45 Uhr das heute journal mit Marietta
Slomka vom gesamten 19 Uhr heute Team
liebe Grüße vielen Dank und einen
schönen Abend für
[Musik]
Sie
guten Abend unser kältoch verlagert
seinen Schwerpunkt jetzt etwas weiter in
den Norden das verändert für uns aber
nichts wir liegen immer noch in seinem
Einflussbereich und das heißt es geht
weiter mit diesen trocken kalten
Wintertagen heute Nacht kann es
allerdings noch mal leicht schneien
zwischen dem Schwarzwald und dem
Bodensee auch im Norden ist der Himmel
durch Nebel oft bedeckt sonst aber
Sternen klar das heißt es kühlt wieder
richtig aus meist auf -5 bis -14° vor
allem über Schnee nur direkt am Wasser
und am oberrein ist es weniger kalt
morgen bleibt es bei dem Dauerfrost -1
bis -4° nur an der See und in den tiefen
Lagen des Südens und des Westens zeigen
sich leichte Plusgrade dazu scheint wie
heute auch oft die Sonne und dieser
unangenehme eisige Ostwind ist etwas
schwächer das bedeutet aber auch dass
sich die Nebelfelder wieder etwas
deutlicher ausbreiten vor allem hier im
Nordosten einige Nebelfelder halten sich
auch im Südwesten und da wo diese
Nebelfelder bleiben da gibt es nur 0 bis
2 Stunden Sonne morgen in einem breiten
Streifen in der Mitte aber 6 bis 8
Stunden und damit ist das maximal
mögliche dabei am Donnerstag gibt es in
der Mitte und im Süden noch mal viel
Sonne von Norden her wird es dann aber
etwas wolkiger und auch etwas weniger
kalt tschüss